Okay. All right. Well, good uh good
afternoon everyone or wherever you're
coming from in the the world. So, this
is the technically the third session on
the fundamentals of active inference uh
reading reading group at the institute.
Uh my name is Fraser. I'm a PhD student
at the University of Glasgow working on
the Defy project. Second year PhD
student going into my second year and uh
I'm I'm very excited to be uh to be your
co-f facilitator for this session. is
going to be good. We're going to do some
cool things. Uh so we're going over
fundamentals of active inference by
Sajiv Namoshi, the new book. Very very
large extension to our contribution to
the literature. We've only had one book
so far. So it's going to be very
excellent uh what we're what we're going
to do here. Just initially maybe before
we get started, I want to kind of
position how I like to run sessions. Um,
I like quite a bit of structure myself
and we'll we'll see uh how that evolves
over time. Um, being transcribed. Very
nice.
So, let me share my screen here. We'll
go over to the code very quickly. I
don't want to spend too much time there.
Share the whole screen. So, everyone
should see my screen now.
I don't want that.
Okay. I'm going to assume everyone can
see uh at least what uh what is on my
screen here.
So yeah, just with respect to
conventions, you know, all all usual
sort of stuff applies for meetings. So
if you want to if you want to ask a
question, I'd you know, raise your hand
using the the Zoom uh affordance to do
so. Um and be respectful and everything.
You guys know what to do there.
Now, really quickly, I I know the book
is very expensive. You know, it's uh
it's no small investment. So, however,
if you go to the Amazon page, there is
the ability to read a sample, uh, a very
small sample, you know, let it be said,
but you can read the whole preface. You
can see the contents page, which is very
helpful. You can read the preface, um,
all of the introduction and even up to
page 10 of chapter one. So, that's not a
lot, but it is um, it is the only amount
that you can get free at the moment. So,
do keep that in mind uh, if you don't
have the book. I know a lot of people
probably don't. So I just come back to
admit some people admit admit admit
and that is
that is uh that is available on the KOD
as well. So,
let's see here. Just really quickly, um
I would be interested how many maybe
just a show of hands, how many people do
actually have the book either physically
or um electronically?
So, if you go to Can I hide that?
Okay. One, two,
three, four, about three people. Okay.
Yeah. So, most people don't have the
book. That's fine.
Yeah. All right. Uh, as I said in the
very original session on Monday, I'm
going to try and run these sessions in
such a way that even if you don't have
the book, you're going to be able to get
something out of this. Uh, of course,
it's going to be a collaborative
discussion anyway. So, you know, we're
not just going to be presenting the
content in the book here. So,
do right. Well, let's take a quick look
at the code. I'm sure most people have
already gone through this um or have
some people have been in the original
session, but over on the left here, we
have all of the different pages that are
constituents of the the the coder page.
This is kind of the main one, the
meetings tab. Uh so, let's go back
people.
Oh, we got Android. Very good.
So this is um this is the the what we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
doing a chapter per week of the book uh
where there's three sessions a week
Daniel, Andrew and myself facilitating
at these time slots here. Maybe this bit
bigger. So at the moment we're just
we're doing kind of an onboarding and
we're going to go through the
introduction of the book which is very
small. Uh it's not it's not much at all.
So this this initial session is going to
be quite preparatory you know as as of
necessity. And next week we're going to
start chapter one and appendix A. So
that's very much positioning kind of
what's the general flavor of active
inference, how does it fit into other
disciplines and appendix A is all kind
of historical precedent about where
active inference comes from and so on.
So it's good positioning. It's good
grounding. That's where we'll actually
leap into some material. So that is this
page. Participants do you know it's
going to take too long to introduce all
ourselves here uh in person. There's
about 13 or 14 people on this call. So
what you can you can come to this tab
here and you know you put down your
name, you can be sadmomous, you can be
anonymous, whatever, your email and then
you know your your about and interests,
who you are, what you're interested in.
And then really crucially, at least for
me, it'd be very useful to know kind of
what you're looking for from the course.
So this is an example here. And then I'
I've put mine my entry in. Can I scroll?
I can't seem to scroll. So you can see
mine here. A few other people put their
details in as well. Uh so if you do want
to introduce yourself this is the best
affordance to do that uh for sure. So
just come back no one else is waiting.
Very nice.
Okay.
Uh there's only a couple really the only
other thing you need to know for now is
this on boarding page. So this is very
much the page that is trying to set the
tone for the course trying to say you
know what what can you expect? Uh it's
not really a course it's a reading
group. So like what are we what are we
doing here? What are we trying to do? Uh
how does a meeting kind of work? Uh how
to contribute. This is this is what this
page is about. So this is probably the
most important page for you to read. Now
uh and to kind of get used to other
pages are are less important
immediately. If you go down here to
chapters, you'll see we have, you know,
a breakdown for all of the chapters in
the book. Uh there's notes that we'll be
able to take later on. That's not too
important.
equations.
This is eventually a place where we'll
have listings of all of the equations in
the book, their latte rendering, and
then some notes that people can take
regarding the equations to elaborate on
on what they mean and so on and how they
relate to other things. So again, that's
quite uh that's not filled in just now.
Discourse, this is just a a link, a hub
for other links in the page, so that's
not too important.
the actual questions if I can find that
here. Yeah, questions. So, this is this
is probably the second most important uh
thing to understand about the code. So,
this is where you'll ask questions
basically. So, for each chapter, right,
chapter one, you can come in here, you
can say what is active inference
and that's a question that is uh now on
the chapter one tab. And if you think
you can maybe answer this or offer some
helpful perspective, you can come along
to answers and dialogue or answers and
discourse.
Which I can't seem to click right now.
That's very annoying. Interesting. Ah,
my mistake. Don't listen to me. You go
add a question, right? Then you type
your question.
Then you select what chapter it's from.
One, two, three, four. Maybe it's from
the appendix. Let's say it's from
appendix B. Uh, and then answers in
discourse. You can, well, people can
start typing here, but if I get out of
this,
get out. Get out. Get out. I can't get
out. Oh dear,
that's very annoying.
I'm trapped. It's over. Okay,
there we go. So, you can see this
appeared under the appendix B tab. And
let's say I'm coming along as someone
who can maybe offer some sort of helpful
perspective. I can come along to this
open uh canvas here and that will take
me back into that question where you can
start typing in here. Uh in order to
use, you know, it's typically a good
idea to use kind of bullet points. You
can go forward slash and come down here
to bulleted list, select enter, and then
you can start typing and you've got
yourself a bulleted list.
So that's very much the main uh kind of
contact point or affordance that you
guys will have and that we will have to
to go through the course itself uh with
which to contribute to the reading
group. So there are a couple of
questions here already. Um I have made
some example ones. So for instance this
question here in the introduction and
I've put it in the introduction because
it's a question that comes up in the
introduction. So what is the
relationship between active inference
and the free energy principle? Well okay
very nice. go here and you see I've got
kind of myself. I'm saying here's here's
a suggested answer. You don't have to
tag yourself. I have in this case um
might be nice to and then I elaborate
you know very quickly what some of the
differences and and points of
divergences are between free energy
principle and active inference. Uh so
that's kind of how that dialectic will
will take place. Uh so do feel free do
feel free to add questions. It's going
to be uh very uh very necessary to to do
that. So to recap the meetings tab this
is the global meetings what's happening
at what times participants you can add
your information on boarding that's all
the details related to the the general
course do read that in your own time and
questions that's the main affordance
you'll have later on you'll see we have
this code tab here
so we do we do have a a GitHub uh for
the the reading group because very much
This book is about practical examples.
It's about, you know, the principles and
algorithms and applications of the free
energy principle for engineers. So, we
want we want to start making things or
at least this book purports to be uh
something that's going to teach you how
to make stuff practically. So, we
haven't set out to claim that we're
going to be doing this necessarily as
part of the group, but it would be nice
to eventually have code examples that we
can talk about together or, you know,
let's say you feel like you want to
implement one of the algorithms in one
of the chapters. This is a canonical
place here where you can do that.
There's nothing there right now.
So that's that's where that is. Uh this
is going to change going forward. It's
going to be versioned going forward, but
that's not going to be central to our to
our uh efforts right now. So I will note
that there are as as you may have um
realized through reading the book, there
are actually examples that are being
prepared by Sanjief himself. Uh they're
not ready yet. uh he's um he very much
wants to have the the examples and the
wider kind of uh module that he's making
uh fulfill a very specific criterion. So
they are coming down the pipe, but he's
very excited uh to to see what we come
up with as well regarding potential
implementations. So that's a bit of
that's kind of a later thing. That is
effectively all you need to know about
the the code page. Let's come back back
up to the meetings
to on boarding.
All right. First of all, are there any
questions about that so far?
I haven't been monitoring the chat
either. Do you mind sharing the coder?
So, does everyone have access to the
coder page first of all? Or put maybe
put your hand up if you don't have
access to the code page.
I see people put it in the chat there.
Uh, I can do the same. Well, it's
already there, so I don't need to.
So, seems as everyone's got access, they
should. You You should have access uh
from the email. Very nice. Okay.
Yes. Okay.
One of the thing actually, one of one of
the things I missed was on the COD page
here.
If you scroll down to this music icon,
if you find uh typos, misprints, issues
in the book, this is actually a place
where Sanjie is going to be looking to
to collect Irata. So, this is actually
something that we can do to help uh the
next version of the book and so on. I've
actually found three already. There's
two in chapter 2 and there's one in
appendix A. So, you just come down here
and you say, "All right, which chapter
is it?" It's one of these.
Whoops.
what page and then what location. So,
you know, this one's page 32, equation
2.14. The existing text says this. I
formatted it in terms of latte. You
don't have to do that if you don't know
what latte is. That's fine. And then
maybe a suggested placement. And then
you can go into even more detail on the
notes canvas here,
which typically you're able to do, but
for some reason I'm not able to do. So,
that's that's important. If you do find
an issue, if you do find a typo, this is
where you would come to discuss it. You
could also put it as a question like may
maybe you don't know if it's a typo, you
know, be good to to make a question.
Yes. All right.
Let's go to on boarding.
So I mean this is going to evolve over
time but what I'm sort of thinking of as
the thing that we will be doing uh
through the course is kind of this here
this this story. So I I'm quite
interested in your go I'm interested in
your feedback on this. So I think you
know the first sort of five minutes
we'll so briefly discuss what we're
going to talk about. Uh then we're going
to move into maybe looking at some
questions from the previous session to
contextualize what we're doing now. Uh,
and then we're going to look at the
overall structure of the chapter that
we're on as a as a unified unit. Kind of
what's the main idea being talked about
in in the chapter that we're on. And
then from there, we're going to take it
down to more specific detail. You know,
okay, what are the core ideas in the
chapter? How do they relate to each
other? And what what if anything can we
say about the the mathematical details?
And is it is it important to understand
this mathematical detail? now uh is it
not can we move that to a later thing a
later chapter
uh and then we'll move into either a
worked example uh like a code example
that someone's created or we'll have a
bit more sort of unstructured discussion
at that point and then we'll have the
ability to maybe formulate questions and
add them to the to the code. So that's
my general thoughts about how this is
going to go. Obviously today we're we're
being a bit uh we're you know it's it's
introductory but um that's I tend to
think that this is a good initial format
for or initial idea about how the format
could go in your participants tab here.
This information will actually tell me
if I need to change that at all. You
know okay maybe people are really really
interested in mathematical detail and
that'll let me know okay well we can we
can spend a bit more time on that or
maybe people are not. Maybe people
really only care about conceptual
understanding typically, you know, then
we'll we'll mitigate the the amount of
mathematical detail. So, it's it is
important for me to to gauge what people
want generally uh and what they're
specifically interested in. So, very
important point there.
I would like to present material and and
discuss things in terms of you know what
is what is core what you kind of have to
understand now in order to understand
things later in the book because active
inference is very much a web of uh
related ideas and it's it's kind of hard
to disentangle them and understand okay
well this thing has to be understood
before this thing um it's very important
to get that right so we should leave
each session with an understanding as to
what the core idea was in a chapter and
the core ideas in a chapter before we
move on. And obviously chapters are
going to preview some material that
we're not going to be able to talk about
um with complete understanding as of
yet. So certain ideas will be introduced
that you'll have to wait for later
chapters to be fully fleshed out and
that's perfectly normal and natural and
you won't understand that you won't
understand those things as they are as
they are exarmed. Uh but that will come.
So and that's that's the whole point of
this book, right? So we have to be
disciplined about deferring related
ideas to their proper time and to to
understand the constituents first. And
then there there are also a whole bunch
of optional um kind of you know tangent
ideas that are floating around that
often get confused with the core of
active inference and are not really um
that core to the to the the fundaments
of what it is to be active inference and
that we'll discuss those as well but
they're not they're not going to be
central. So we really want want to keep
our eye fixed on the the core central
ideas in each chapter.
So yeah, I mean as I say you guys it
would be good to try and read uh the
chapter before you know ahead of time uh
to formulate questions ahead of time uh
and to to asynchronously engage on that
that side of the page. But as I say
you're not expected to master every
figure, every equation, every
implementation detail. You're certainly
not going to be asked to do such things.
Um, but if you do want to, as I say, if
you do want to do code examples later
on, that's going to be something that's
available. I'm going to contribute some
code examples myself. And hopefully I'm
committed to, you know, providing some
sort of structure, uh, and clearly
denoting what I think is core, what I
think should be deferred, and what I
think is optional. Obviously, that's a
debate that can be had. Um, but that's
that's what I'm taking to be my my
position with respect to you guys.
Alrighty,
on to here.
What have I got written down here?
Good. Okay,
I want to I want to move on to the
actual content of the book now, the the
introduction. But before I do, does
anyone have any questions?
Maybe I can stop sharing very quickly.
Oh dear, I hope I was sharing for that.
I guess we'll find out. So, raise hand
for if there are uh questions to to ask
in person now.
Otherwise, we'll go into the first
chapter. Well, the introduction.
All right.
Share screen. Share screen. Very good.
So I mean I can really do that through
the the Amazon page here. I hopefully
we are able to click on that.
All right.
I believe I'm sharing.
Please unmute and complain if if I'm not
sharing
right here. Okay. So, this is the the
free sample. I don't know how if this
needs to be zoomed in a bit more.
Can't zoom in anymore.
Can't zoom at all. Oh, there we go.
One detail I should note is Come on. We
can't uh we we can't share directly the
contents of the book uh electron elect
electronically or otherwise but we do
have access to all of the code all of
the latte code for all the equations and
all of the figures and we have it we
have permission to share the figures and
so on. So any figure that anyone's
concerned about or any equation we can
share that directly and we can talk
about it screenshot it and so on put it
in the coda but we can't share the book
other than through this uh free sample
here. I don't know. This is gonna This
is not uh loading in real time very
well. I thought it would.
What I can do is stop sharing that and
bring up the PDF instead very quickly.
Okay.
Uh, I can find it.
Okay, perfect.
I am sharing. Ah, thank you, Ben.
sharing again. Okay,
so this is part of the free sample. So
it's perfectly legitimate for me to show
you this. These this is the the table of
contents for the book. So
today we're going to just quickly look
at the introduction. There's actually
not much to cover there, but it's in
three parts. So we have part one,
fundamentals. Then we have part two the
core of active inference active
inference core. And then we have part
three which is applications and
extensions. So really the core of the
book for our purposes is kind of part
two. That's where
you know active inference qua active
inference lives in terms of its
presentation here. But in order to get
there there is a lot of you know
material that we need to understand
before we can understand active
inference. And that's the point of part
one.
So next week we're going to be starting
out with chapter one at the hypothesis
testing brain. Not a very big chapter,
okay, but obviously more than
introduction. Chapter two is quite
enormous. Lots of stuff to get through
there. Chapter three, combining learning
and inference again fairly big. So we
are going to be moving at a pretty brisk
pace which is going to make um you know
careful elaborate working out of the
details of certain things in a session
kind of hard to do. So sessions like
this are going to be very conceptual.
We're going to be very broad strokes and
the asynchronous questions via the
coder. They're going to be where we have
the affordance for more detail because
there just isn't a lot of time in a
session like this unfortunately.
So what do we what do we do? We start
out thinking about how do we infer
hidden states? Uh how do we do learning?
What does it mean to do variational
basian inference? That's kind of one of
the core things in active inference.
That's chapter four. And then chapter
five is about this other thing
predictive coding that's related to
active inference. And that's that's all
the fundamentals dealt with at that
point. Part two then obviously this is
the core of active inference. What does
that mean for it to be the core of
active inference? The way that Sanjie
has uh you know chosen to present the
material is as lots all of the different
algorithms that are used in active
inference to to fulfill the disa of
active inference. So the first kind of
you know significant algorithm is this
thing called generalized filtering for
perception. I'm going to go through that
and we have active generalized
filtering. How is that different to
generalized filtering? We we'll find out
what you know how and why later. Then we
go into learning and hierarchical models
and learning and hierarchical models and
continuous state spaces. So we're going
to look at the difference between
discrete and continuous state spaces.
That's quite a big difference and we'll
learn why that's a big difference. Uh
and then really kind of the jewel of a
lot of recent work in active inference
is active inference in partially
observable markoff decision processes.
This is where you're planning and you're
doing all kinds of very sophisticated
things to select actions. And much of
that may not make sense right now, but
it will uh once we once we get to it. Uh
and then chapter 10, this is about
learning. How does learning fit into
inference? Uh how do we have learning
algorithms alongside of inference
algorithms? Uh, very exciting material.
Part three, applications and extensions.
There's all kinds of modifications and
extensions to base active inference that
exist. Um, there's different free
energies. There's different expressions
for the same free energy. Um, there's
even different planning algorithms. So,
there's a lot of various things that
could be, you know, termed active
inference or fall under the rubric of
active inference.
Very cool chapter, at least close to my
heart, is active inference on factor
graph models. We'll see what that means
later on. So this is the work of of many
people, but that's that's a big area
that's up and coming. And then really
the last sort of parts of the book about
are about applications. So chapter 13 is
about robotics, you know, and active
inference in robotics. How does this
work? What are the challenges? Uh what
are the the promises that active
inference, you know, can deliver maybe.
And then chapter 14, this is the last
chapter. This is very much about where
act kind of what what is the summary
statement about what active inference is
and where is it going as a field um and
what does it what is its imports you
know how does it u what does it have to
say about the nature of the brain and
very very high questions like that so
that is the book that's the core content
of the book that was a very quick
summary obviously then you get into the
appendices now the appendices are are
excellent they're they're long actually
the book itself was much longer than
this published version. A lot of the
material has been moved to the
appendices. So, as I say, next session
we're going to be looking at appendix A,
kind of history and even the future of
active inference. This is very, very
good grounding and historical context
for where active inference comes from.
I'd strongly recommend reading that
alongside chapter one. Excellent
material, but again, it's not core,
although it does help to to
contextualize everything. That's that's
the point. B, appendix B, this is just
mathematical notation. There's a lot of
mathematics in this book. There's a lot
of mathematics in active inference and
the literature is often contradictory
with respect to how it depicts things
and how it chooses to notate things. So
there is a there is a standard notation
in this book and appendix B is just just
elaborating that you know what do we
actually how do we index into arrays um
you know all the all the all the
notation. So that's not too exciting.
Appendix C is enormous. It's quite a big
appendix. It is in some sense the
fundamental mathematics that it would be
nice for you to know in order to to read
the book and get the most out of it. So
it's a quick very very quick um
lightning tour of all of the maths
involved. So linear algebra, probability
theory, you know, logarithms, uh we go
into calculus, multivariable calculus
somewhere,
uh plate notation for probabilistic
models, all of that stuff. So if you are
a bit rusty on on your maths or maybe
you don't know certain things, appendix
C is purports to be the kind of map as
to what you should know mathematically
or what would be helpful to know
mathematically in order to get the most
out of the book. So
again the book is written in such a way
that if you don't know any maths you
should be able to read the text and
understand the core ideas. That's
exactly what we're going to be doing.
But yeah, appendix C for for the
mathematical uh background and appendix
D is all of the different forms of free
energy. We'll see what free energy is
later. Uh it's very it's core it's
fundamental to active inference but
there's many many different ways of
expressing it and appendix is just a
compilation of all those those ways.
So that is that is the contents. So
again you should keep in mind three
level the global three-le structure
fundamentals active inference core and
then extensions. So that raises the
point and again you can you can come
back and see this in the
the free sample.
It's not going to load in time. There's
a Oh, maybe it will. Hang on.
So that's the the content. There's the
preface. Very short. The introduction.
The main thing in the introduction I
would say that is important to
understand is this figure here. So
hopefully I'm sharing come on come on
uh it's not very large. It's very laggy.
Okay. And this this is just a visual
depiction of everything I just said in a
much more succinct manner than how I
just said it. So it's a depiction of the
chapters in the book. they're grouping
into parts and then their relationship
to one another. So you see you've got
part one, part two, part three. Um part
one is is con constitutes chapters one
to five. And then these boxes on the
side here, they denote the um the
dependencies. So the chapters that you
should read prior to chapter, you know,
the chapter that's over here. So chapter
two, you should read chapter one before
you've read chapter two. You know,
pretty standard. Chapter three, you
should read chapter two before chapter
one. Chapter 3. So, but if we look at
chapter four here, we've got this one,
two, it would be good to read one and
two before chapter four. And there's
this dotted chapter 3. That means it
would be nice to read chapter 3. It
would be, you know, ideal, but it's it's
recommended. It's not really required.
So, you see, chapter 3 is kind of a
recommendation for actually most of the
book. Uh, so strictly speaking, you
could read all the way up to, you know,
well, pretty much the entire book
without reading chapter 3. but it would
be recommended is the idea. So that's
kind of how to interpret this diagram.
So from that you can see well chapter
one and two are you know they're
fundamental they're requirements for the
entire book. Um they're they're going to
be very very important. So there are
some things in the book that are going
to be more important than others core
ideas uh you know to to really
understand before understanding the
other core ideas. And that's what this
diagram gets across uh pretty well. So I
I tend to think that's the most
important thing to get out of the
introduction. Um other he does talk
about
how you know who this book is for uh and
how to read it. So there's there's
various reading styles that he talks
about. I'm afraid the latency is is too
bad. It wasn't very it was fine before I
was sharing.
Um but we're we're going to be catering
to to all reading styles here. So
there's no problem around that.
All right.
Let me stop sharing temporarily. Any are
there any questions about that at all?
Was anything unclear or was anything
strange in what I what I said?
Oh, you've just started building a
Haskell library based on Dre's work.
Very, very exciting. Ben, I'm going to
be chasing you on to talk about that.
That's excellent. So, that's Well,
that's chapter 13. That's that's a long
way off for us just now.
Okay. All right. Well,
I think uh I think that's good. I think
everyone's happy with that. Again, do
ask questions if you're unsure. You
know, perfectly uh fine to do.
Yes. Okay. Uh right. Let's quickly do
that. So, the last thing I want to do
before I kind of open it up to general
discussion
is I want to come back to the questions
tab.
questions here.
I did talk about this before, but I I
wanted to I missed talking about what
makes a good question, you know? So,
I've got some example questions here.
I've got an example good and an example
bad. So, an example bad question is what
is active inference? So, let's go here
into let's get rid of that
here. So this is not a great question
because in some sense the whole book is
about active inference and it's very
unspecific. It's very global. Um there's
any number of ways that this could be
attacked. So we want to be specific with
our questions. You know another kind of
flavor of what this kind of question
could be and and a different way in
which it could be bad is you have lots
of questions string together. So how
does X, Y, and Zed relate to active
inference? But does that mean that Y and
Zed are really W? That's actually a
whole bunch of questions. Okay. So a
good question by comparison is like
this. So
you know in the introduction active
inference is described as a framework.
What distinguishes it from a general
principle like the EF? So that's a very
specific question and it's also tied to
the text you know so it's very
particular. Uh it's remit is understood
and it's it's it sort of hangs together
as a as a single thing as opposed to a
whole bunch of things. So those are
those are some general guidelines about
how to ask questions. I tend to think
those are good guidelines. um dispense
with them as you as you please but
nevertheless that is my recommendation.
So that was an important to uh to cover
I think
to meetings now what else?
All right that's pretty much everything
I wanted to say by means of uh
preparatory material.
So if I stop sharing, I guess the only
thing before before we open it up for
some questions is you it is this is
going to be you are going to be
confused. Um active inference is
notoriously difficult to understand.
It's very technical. Uh and that's
perfectly natural and normal and that's
why we're doing this group, you know, so
that we can be confused together in a
way that we can ameliate our mutual
confusion. So do not worry. Uh it's
going to be it's going to be fine.
Okay. Now, I I'd like that to be the end
of of all the logistics. Is there
anything that anyone would like to ask
in question in in person at at this
point in time?
If not, I will assume that I have been
completely clear about everything and
indeed utterly perfect with respect to
my delivery. So, good to good to see
that I have been.
Hi, kid.
Andrew, my uh esteemed co-f facilitator,
is there anything that you would like to
say or uh maybe add to or anything you
think I've missed?
I think you're doing great, Frasier. Uh
I think it was very informative and
clear. I like the uh demonstration of
asking and answering questions. Um did
you get to the other parts of the KOD?
Sorry, I was just a little bit late. Did
you get to the other parts of the kod
that show like resources or like how
people can search the the live streams?
Um I think it's nice for people to be a
little bit more aware of like different
kinds of resources they have available
outside of this textbook that just sort
of are readily available in the
>> Yeah, it's a good point. I I didn't
share those uh but those are available.
So if we go over to here on the coder
there there is this resources tab which
is what Andrew is talking about and this
is just a compilation of you know people
have added what they think are relevant
or or useful papers and articles about
active inference that can provide a bit
more context than just the book itself.
Obviously that's going to be quite
important for people who don't have the
book uh to be able to follow along with
uh with other material. Uh that's
certainly very possible. I think that's
a great idea actually. I might um I
might try and collect this section such
that in some sense it's a substitute for
the book. That's going to be hard to do.
Um but I think it's going to be
necessary to look at. So yeah there
there's papers and articles. There are
well there are videos uh you know that
have been quite influential in in the in
the field. Books I actually added a book
myself the self-evidencing brain by
Jakobi. This actually came out this
year. Um this is an excellent kind of
introduction to active inference in the
free energy principle at a very high
conceptual philosophical level. So
Yakapowi is a philosopher in Australia.
I that's where I come from. Very pretty
very happy to see a fellow Australian.
Um this is a this is a great book. So
yeah, there's tons of material there. Uh
and there's some other other papers as
well. We'll we'll I think we'll flesh
this out in a way that's helpful for
people who don't have the book. So thank
you for reminding me of that, Andrew.
Great great suggestion.
Also, another quick note, if you're
intending to continue sharing your
screen, you may want to reshare it, but
I think everything you you said was
useful regardless of being able to see
your screen or not. So,
>> am I am I not sharing my screen just
now?
>> No, not currently. I think you you
turned it off before I sort of came in
and brought it back up again. I'm
>> sorry, people. I swear I'm a
professional uh some days of the week.
I actually can't get back to the tab now
either, which is very annoying.
Oh boy.
Get rid of that. Come in here. All
right. Very quickly, because I know
repeating yourself is incredibly
annoying. So, if I go back to the code,
hopefully I'm sharing now.
Okay.
>> Yes, you. Yes, you are.
>> Okay. So, along here on the side panel,
there's this tab, resources, and then
you have papers and articles that people
put in. You have videos. These are
canonical videos and kind of the law of
active inference. And then you have
books. And I was saying, okay, there's
this cool book, the self-evidencing
agent by Yakapowi. That's what my my
suggestion as as it's much much less
expensive than the uh than the
fundamentals of active infants book. I
do recommend it. Very excellent book. So
that's where you can find some more
resources. Yeah. Okay. Apologies for
that lack of sharing.
Which page was that? Sorry. So it's
resources. I might put it in the chat.
There we go. That's the page.
Excellent.
Okay. All right. Well, let me stop
sharing real quick.
I don't want to I don't want to tax
anyone's time and attention any more
than we need to. That's kind of the the
the structure of the the group as at
least in so far as I conceive of it. I
want to reiterate, please do uh offer
your suggestions in your participants
tab section and even in the questions as
to how we could uh change kind of the
structure and so on. But at least that's
what I conceive of as these sessions
going forward. So I see there's a
question in the chat. have to jump off
now. I'm very excited. All right, cool.
I think uh I think we uh we can end it
there. Unless there is anything that
anyone wants to ask as a final question
uh for this session, please do not uh
hesitate. So,
all right.
Well, we went to Oh, hang on. We got
Sylvia. That's uh Hello, Silia.
>> Hi. Um I thought we're going to discuss
the introduction or anything but um I I
actually would like to hear from both of
you and phrase of your trajectory of
learning especially the technical
aspects like the maths or the
computational models of active inference
because I I believe both of you if I
remember correctly are not from a
cognitive science background or like say
a neuroscience background. So you
definitely have a different you probably
come in at influence with a different
perspectives and I thought your
perspectives might be very valuable for
people in the testbook group who are
also not from the field and want to
learn more. How did you guys learn it?
Um how did you overcome the barriers
um of the things that you don't know
before? How did you navigate that
uncertainty basically?
>> Yeah, excellent. I I'll guess I'll go
first. Great question by the That's
that's excellent. Um I think Andrew, you
actually are from a cognitive modeling
back or at least a a social science
background. Is it am I correct there?
>> You're you're muted by the way if you're
>> It's annoyingly difficult to answer that
question. Um uh I mean if you don't mind
maybe I could kind of go first uh just
kind of answer the question too. And I
I'm also really looking forward to
hearing about um sort of your path as
opposed to to mine. So my background is
kind of a mix. I very much did a lot of
work in um sort of social sciences and
in the humanities. I became interested
in in history during my undergraduate
and uh and double majored with
economics. And so a lot of my interests
were driven by actually understanding
people. economics had to do with you
know folks from different low-income
statuses or understanding like
interconnectivity between markets and
resource availability and and and things
like that. Uh history was just again
about people but also theoretically how
do you construct a history? What
justifies uses of different kinds of
narratives? What counts as evidence
whenever you whenever you produce an
account? All these things. So it it's
quite a a blend of things. And then that
also involved like sort of the history
of um philosophy and philosophy of mind
and then from there getting interests in
in psychoanalysis and psychology and all
the rest. So, it's a it's a very deeply
like almost purely theoretical
um kind of um background that I that I
had aside from using like you know
documents as your as your primary data
or evidence that you're referring to uh
as far as history goes or some kind of
financial quant purely quantitative
financial information for looking at
like uh economics and um so yeah getting
into computational modeling was was
quite a hurdle. um in the sense of it
just felt like I was in entirely new
territory. Um and it wasn't until um a
colleague of mine who went to school for
data science uh made me aware that I
already sort of knew machine learning.
And I said, "What do you mean I already
know machine learning?" Uh and he said,
"Well, you studied economics." And I
said, "Yes." And he said, "So you had to
take a statistics class or two?" And I
said, "Sure." And he said, "You know
what linear regression is?" And I said,
"Yes." And he said, "So you know machine
learning?" And a light bulb went off in
my head. So I think uh for those who
don't know what linear regression is and
the like um I think what's been most
useful is taking what you do know and
taking what you are genuinely interested
in uh just kind of facilitate sort of um
the drive for learning the exploratory
drive for epistemic value. Uh just take
what you're already interested in and
see how you might be able to find a way
to make that at least partially
foundational for how you start to enter
into this new material. uh and for this
textbook alone uh chapter two not
chapter 1 but chapter 2 right after that
starts more deeply getting into sort of
like uh mathematical notation and
talking about deterministic and
nonlinear functions and all those sorts
of things. Um that's about the extent of
what I knew. Uh it was just the material
of chapter 2 until I started kind of
getting deeper uh later in my my
academic career. So yeah, um just work
with what you know and and just slowly
start tying the threads and seeing what
what makes sense whenever you learn
something new and then what doesn't and
bridging between what you already know
with with what you need to know. Uh so I
hope that was useful. But yeah, I think
Frasier, you're a little bit more on
the, if I'm not mistaken, the kind of
computer science and engineering uh side
of things, which is uh an area that did
not used to interest me whenever I was
younger, and now it's one of the most
interesting things to me. So, I'm
wondering how someone from from that
realm kind of arrives at Active
Influence.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, first of all, thank
you. That was that was excellent. I I
second everything that you said um at
least generally in terms of advice and
everything. But yeah, my my trajectory
is a bit different. Um I started out in
physics and philosophy. Uh I would
regard I would actually regard
philosophy as my fundamental interests.
Uh and then I switched over into
mathematics and computer science. Uh I
was very much interested in the notion
of what an agent is. This is totally
obsessing me. Um you know how how do we
describe agency? How do we implement
agents? Um what is it fundamentally to
be an agent? uh you know precisely and
technically. So I started looking around
for um and I knew well okay you know
artificial intelligence that's where
this is this is one of the areas or one
of the domains where this question is
quite hot and uh of of immense
relevance. It's it's probably a good
idea if I go into AI. So that's kind of
my that was my initial fuzzy thought and
direction. You know I love technical
things. I like mathematics. I like these
deep questions and agency seems to be
kind of something that that unifies them
all. So I looked around for extant um
let's say paradigms in machine learning
and artificial intelligence that really
deal with this question directly. What
is an agent? And I found reinforcement
learning pretty quickly. Um so you know
through my undergrad and things like
that I got very interested in
reinforcement learning algorithms
creating little agents to play games and
so on. um you know trying to understand
and and and conceptualize the question
of agency in terms of that paradigm and
uh all the way through you know I I do a
lot of reading in uh cognitive science
and philosophy and it just happened I
was watching a live stream one day with
with a a favorite cognitive scientist of
mine and they were talking about this
new thing called predictive processing
and how it's a you know there's this
central quantity called variational free
energy you minimize that and then you
get a very felicitus agent that's
separated from the environment I thought
oh wow these are all very uh central
questions that I've wanted to get my
teeth sunken into, but I haven't found a
home, a formal mathematical home to talk
about them. And here it is. It's this
thing called active inference,
apparently. Uh and from then on, I've
been obsessed. I've been just
voraciously,
you know, looking uh around for papers
and and and uh videos on active
inference. What is this active inference
thing? I very quickly found the active
inference institute. So I I just you
know devoured lots of live streams on
active inference. I became an intern at
the active inference institute uh
shortly after my my honors degree. So
yes I I did computer science and
mathematics and then I did an honors
degree in in computer science uh and I
started looking at deep deep active
inference trying to scale it up and that
sort of thing. So that was my initial
trajectory. But how how did I actually
uh get into the material? Uh fortunately
my my my
background and training and and work in
mathematics has served me greatly. You
know there's a whole language there to
draw on to then be able to see through
the language of matrices and
differential equations and so on to the
the underlying ideas in active
inference. So I'm quite fortunate in
that I had that initial training to to
you know help me with respect to these
abstract questions in active inference.
um just you know doing maths and
computer science. So I don't know if
that was very helpful in in trying to
explain how to get into what was
happening because I must say at my
university um no one had even heard of
active inference. So, you know, I came
to my honor supervisor and said, "Oh,
this is active inferencing. This sounds
cool." But, uh, it it was just me kind
of on my own autodidactically, you know,
looking at videos, looking at live
streams trying to, you know, figure out
the, uh, the documentation for certain
software packages like PMDP and and RX
infer these these kind of implement
parts of active inference. So, it was a
lot of just obsession uh on the
weekends, you know, trying to figure out
how to how to make sense of this stuff.
uh and then know I'm part of a PhD
program now and I spent all day every
day uh thinking about reasoning about
active inference. So hopefully there was
something useful in that answer of mine
>> but for yeah sorry thank you both for
sharing. I do think it's very useful and
it's always very inspiring to hear how
people come into active influence and
how people can learn in a very different
way and because it's an
interdisciplinary field in accent. So I
hope that everyone here from a very
different background could feel that
this could be a home for them as well.
And it's always an open discussion to
hear different perspectives rather than
thinking that we lack something because
we are not originally from the field or
because we don't know the math.
No, I completely agree and I must say
that's um that's kind of Sanjie's big
hope with this book is that hopefully
what he has done and what we will do in
these sessions is be able to draw you
know just well be able to see the
relationships between the core ideas and
active inference right because a lot of
the time you read a paper or you read
some code documentation and it's free
energy this and it's planning that and
it's you know approximate posterior here
and it's it's very it's kind of clear or
it's assumed that you already know what
the relationships are between these
things. Uh but the whole point of this
book and the whole point of this session
is to really tease out what are what are
the things what are the concepts and
then what are the relationships between
them and we're hopefully going to be
doing this in a way that's catering to
to people from all kinds of different
perspectives as you say. So yeah, that's
that's the mission uh for what we're
doing here. So cool.
I'll also add that uh the uh I don't
know Frasier if you already brought up
the 2022
textbook or not but uh for just for
those who
>> you haven't okay uh I'll just briefly
kind of drop that uh is a um
uh a link in the chat um but this book
which we will no longer be primarily
discussing uh sadly going forward uh was
the the previous textbook And so um it's
it's very useful in that it's you know
first it's it's shorter uh there's more
kind of explanation of um sort of the
the theoretics and and other kinds of
like empirical experiments that were
done whereas I think Sanjieves is
primarily focused on being very thorough
about sort of the maths and and
providing a more um unified mathematical
notation and just sort of way of
thinking about active inference models.
mod. Um some brief notes on that is that
like we we have continuous time models,
discrete time models, hierarchical and
hybrid models. So there's so many
different kinds and this has led to
different kinds of research trajectories
have been taken in terms of you know who
is publishing about what and so that has
led to as with many areas of science you
know not everyone kind of uses the same
uniform notation. So even this 2022
textbook will sort of have its own
notation. It's not dramatically
different from what uh in fact it's very
similar to what Sanjieve is using. I'm
sure he's he's relying on this textbook
a lot. Um but yeah, in any case the the
the textbook is is shorter. We do have a
previous KOD that has many built out
questions and answers. uh I think it's a
very useful uh learning resource for for
anyone who especially those who want to
follow along in these textbook group
sessions but cannot necessarily yet
afford uh fundamentals um but would
still like to be able to like
participate um which of course anyone is
still welcome to do that uh equally
valid if you don't have the book yet but
uh I'm sure you'd like to have something
worthwhile and I think the 2022 textbook
uh is what helped the the most and that
is that is on my personal background how
I most thoroughly came into active
inference. I mean I there's I did some
weird jumping around where I I started
moving into sort of um data and then
with the social science stuff realized I
could maybe do something more empirical
with neuroiming and then one thing led
to another and I was like oh Carl
Fristen has invented like you know a
variety of methods for sort of analyzing
neuroiming data building out SPM uh
dynamical causal modeling uh and all the
rest. So um so yeah uh then I eventually
arrived at the 2022 textbook. So
definitely recommend that for for anyone
interested. Um but yeah, it's such an
interdisciplinary
sort of field. Um the final chapter of
the 2022 textbook like kind of lays out
like here are the relationships between
active inference and you know
neuroscience uh uh control theory,
cybernetics, economics, psychology, the
study of emotion so on and so on and so
on uh psychiatry and so um yeah that
that's also a a good partial answer to
the question of like what are the
different routes one can take to active
emperence. there there have been many
recorded and they continue to expand
over time. So
>> I'll just second that. I mean actually
the the the 2022 parallel textbook was
very very central in my uh initial uh
explorations in active inference. It was
so it was actually so instrumental that
I even forgot about it as you know
something that was my initial ingress.
So that was that was one of my first
contact points with active imprint
itself. Uh and it is a beautiful book.
It's a wonderful book. Uh it's very it
is very conceptual. It is very detailed
in places. Um it does tend to rub people
the wrong way in some respect. It does
assume a lot of the reader. You know, it
just kind of assumes that you're an
expert in some sense and you neuro
imaging and this this kind of thing. It
doesn't really, but um that's hopefully
where this next book is going to fill
the gap if there was a gap uh you know
with respect to the the fine grain
details. So yeah, second second that for
sure.
Well, we are we're at the end of the
hour. Uh does anyone have any any more
live questions to ask before we uh
before we split up for for the first
session or the third session? This is I
guess
going once, going twice, going three
times.
All right. Well, it's been a pleasure,
guys. Um we're going to jump into some
actual material uh next week with uh you
know, chapter one and appendix A. I
think we're going to we're going to have
some cool times. It's going to be good.
Fill out the questions table. fill out
your participant section and uh we'll
see you next week. So, good to have you.
>> Thanks everyone.
>> Thank you.
>> Bye.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Bye. Bye.